seconds so for people who just arrived
at birday they have this rule everything
starts at least 10 minutes after the
hour unbelievable nobody shows up before
10 minutes after the suppos to start
except for the except for we are Oasis
here so what happens when people show up
10 minutes late to the 10 minutes after
they do they do
that's you R your proc okay so welcome
everyone to the afternoon session we
have two talks on constraint
satisfaction the first will be given by
K thank you um good afternoon everyone
so first thanks to the organizers for
inviting um I'm going to talk about our
work this is Joint work with anab
bachara who is a faculty member at N US
Singapore pan aduri who is an audience
faculty member at IA State and and we V
know chandran who is at NE University of
Nebraska so I guess it's kind of the
theme of the day we had um you know no
relationship to the world of semirings
and then well was spending sabatical at
uh in Singapore and also bod was there
for sabatical and then well got us into
the world of semi rings so he introduce
us to this problem I'm going to talk
about what we have and um at least to it
looks like there are lots of interesting
questions to
pursue uh okay so um I kind of come from
the world of satisfiability Boolean uh
satisfiability so in this world you have
a formula and uh the kind of question is
is there a truth assignment to the
variable so that the formula evaluat to
True um in this case as you can see
there's no uh such truth
assignment
and then well said you know what you
should look at through the world of semi
ring so there's a semi ring there's a
interpretation for The Operators and now
you can ask that the same question uh
can be formulated as compute the maximum
value over all
interpretations and as you can see a
formula is satisfiable if and only if
the maximum value evaluates to one
okay now we start asking well what
happens Beyond bullan interpretation so
maybe if you look at uh V be uh semiring
interpretation which is kind of very
nice in sense and our Boolean is also
multiplier or our Boolean is also Max so
the only thing that changes is the
domain so the domain now is
01 and we had to talk about negation so
let's say we are focus on neg as 1 - x
I'll come back to this to comment a
little
bit and now the question we can ask is
well compute the maximum value over all
interpretations um for the
formula that we have here the maximum is
over this polinomial both of them turn
out to be symmetric so we can just focus
on one of these and the maximum value
that turns out here is
0.25 so a formula that is unsatisfiable
can have a value somewhere between 0 and
one you can see I only have 10 slides so
if there are any questions please ask
there and the thing that I want to talk
about here is that there are some very
very cool and simple things you can do
so how to maximize this you can say you
can and take this expression X2 into 1 -
X2 T value at or X1 into 1 - X1 T value
at05 yeah going to ask the same question
the morning so maximum with respect to
what
order so we are considering the natural
order let's say
yeah right so some uh simple observation
the formula is satisfiable if and only
if the maximum value is one here we are
going to consider the formula in the neg
normal form in particular here I had
written what is called conjunctive
normal form so if it is satisfiable then
uh the value you can evaluate to one
okay just to make sure na observations
do you apply distributivity here to get
to that expression am I am I correct
yeah yeah
exactly uh there is always um as we ched
more with Val the negation turns out to
be um bit of Eis Hill in this area so
what we are looking at is one
interpretation negation which is 1 minus
X in case of VB and similar
interpretation for other semi
Rings the um results I'll talk about in
particular I'll show upper and lower
bounds any kind of reasonable
interpretation works out so all we need
is negation of negation should be same
and then negation of uh zero to be one
and so on do you define minus how do
Define
minus um yeah so minus in this it will
depend on um this is really just looking
at the U all we want is the zero
elements so the one element to
Define I mean for every searing it is
kind of very easy to see what we are
looking at it okay so this is just the
additive inverse that you're looking at
yeah
uh so the semi rings that we looked at
are you know the wib semi ring there is
motivation for it coming from database
Provence as we looked at there's also
work in the world of csps there was a
lot of work and also from hidden Marco
models uh tropical searing fuzzy searing
excess control searing so our results
apply uh to all these different
semirings so the problem that we looked
at is that you have a given a semi ring
and a formula which is in neg normal
form uh the problem of interest is
compute the maximum
value and the question we are looking at
is what is the complexity of this
problem okay it turns out there was a
long history of work that in the CSP
community that tried to develop uh
techniques for it but surprisingly we
didn't find any work on computational
complexity perspective for cases other
than bullan sing so all these questions
very natural questions someh out turned
out to
be to be
studied and our result is that in case
of fuzzy and excess
control you can the complex is same as
the Boolean case so can be reduced to
the Boolean case in case of VB and
tropical because those are isomorphic to
each
the complexity of this
problem lies between FP so this is a
polinomial Time turing machine that can
make calls to NP Oracle in particular if
you allow logarithmically many calls to
NP Oracle so this is hard for the FP to
NP the log
calls and it lies in the class polom
many call to NP
Oracle
you know
that yeah so we are going to I'll talk
about both the
side and uh I think you should I hope
you will enjoy for next 15 minutes the
proof arguments are also very simple and
beautiful so let me get you through
those
arguments are the results clear so it is
hard for FP to logarithmic manic also NP
Oracle is contain in polom manic also
nple I'm I'm still confused about the
minus for the various semur Rings you
showed us like four sem rings on the
previous slide yeah but it's not obvious
what the minus operator should be for
each of them so maybe I can come back to
it later so it's really looking at the
top and defining the minus value on from
the top but of course for excess control
we have to
Define
yeah do you need a to order H yeah so we
are assuming the natural order yeah in
case of v b is
just between Z and
one you can guess the inition of the
minus for thetical semi R so you map
infinite to zero and one to one yeah
matter how you map everything between
zero and infinite to each other it's not
like not OB question like one over yeah
yeah
about the connection to CSP we cannot
see this problem as mapping to to a
structure sorry if we think about the
connection to CSP can we see this as I
have
structure I mean I'm kind of doing
thinking you have a formula and the
domain elements take value between Z and
one okay so let me show you how we can
there are two results here one is how do
we show the upper bond that you can
solve the problem by making polom many
calls to NP
Oracle and now simple idea would be that
we we should do a binary search because
the values are between zero and one so
you try to do a binary search by making
multiple calls that is the optimum value
greater than some value
B the issue here is that um you can take
any all the real values so how do we
know where to
stop so since the value can be any real
number so we don't know how to
stop and it's also not hard to see that
it can really take infinitely many
values given
expression
so here is how it uh works out so let's
go back to the simple formula we
considered and let's try to think about
what's the optimal there is some optimal
interpretation and uh suppose I told you
I'm going to focus right now on the CNF
when things are represented in a
conjunctive normal form but everything
generalizes to neg normal form because
you can work over proof
trees so in casee of C if suppose I told
you that from each of the
Clauses the literal that takes the
maximum
value right so for example let's say I
promise you that in the optimal
interpretation in this Clause the
literal that takes the maximum value is
not
X2 if you know it then we know that
the P head of f is pi head of X1 * pi
head of X2 * pi head of not X2 then we
can rewrite in this expression
here
okay the next step is going to be well
if you know this is the expression then
we can maximize this for both Pi head of
X1 and Pi head of x two and those
maximum values are 1
and5 so we can generalize this idea
let's just again focus on the
CNF if you knew that XI takes the
maximum value in let's say lii closes
and not exite X the maximum value in ki
closes then what would the value Pi head
of f look like it will look like P head
of XI to the power Li * 1 - pi head of
XI to^ K it will be product of all of
them I'm behind so in the second fo
point the property you used here is the
selectivity property of the sing
addition the ma right so this say you
choose one of them is the ma so that
allows you to
doity no no right now the way to
understand is suppose I told you from
each of the Clauses which of the
literals contribute to the maximum then
what would the um formula evalate to it
will be really you know you had the end
so it's product of the interpretation
for every clause and for every Clause I
tell you which you know what the maximum
evales to so it evales to one of the
literals right but only because you have
a selectivity property the max of .8
and99 if it's multiplication then it
doesn't work so the itivity means the
operator plus is always one of the two
inputs all right so in that
case we can maximize this expression
well I mean what is this expression this
is
really x i to the^ Li 1 minus to the^ K
so the maximum value turns out to be
following so if I know that from each of
the closes which of the literals take
the maximum
value I can compute the maximum
value just by knowing that
information and now we know that the
maximum possible values are always going
to be of the following
form and this turns out to be uh again
well studied um sequence of number these
are far sequences so there are only
exponentially many maximum possible
values so we can do a binary search over
the space of all the exponentially many
possible values so the key observation
is that while the formula can take
infinitely many I mean it can take any
real value so but the maximums can only
be exponentially many so you can do a
search binary search over those maximum
values now this a binary search kind of
works
out okay so what about it being hard so
can we show some hardness and in this
case it turns out that we can show that
it is as hard as Mex set why so um so
the key technical LMA that allows us to
prove this is if given a formula in CNF
and then again things again generalized
to the neg normal
form if you have a CNF formula with M
closes
and it has R is the maximum number of
satisfiable closes then the maximum
value the formula can take in the v Bing
is 1x 4 to the m minus
r the proof is again relying on that
maximum Valu are of this
and then working out a little bit about
Allis and
kis right
so well here is kind of again a very
simple reduction that should work out we
take a Formula F we are going to reduce
the reduction Works about by taking a
Formula F we'll construct another f
Prime where essentially every Clause of
CI we replace by Ci or Yi and not
Yi okay so we doubled the number of
closes and we introduced new fresh
variables
yis now I would like to claim that the
optimal value for f
Prime is really 1X 4 to the m minus r
why
so
well I can actually give a very simple
interpretation so that this Optimum is
achieved what's that
interpretation look at the me set
assignment so either all the closure
that get satisfied we don't have to
worry about just take the the max at
assignment and for the closes that are
not satisfied there Yi takes value
half and there are exactly M minus r
closes that are not satisfied so the max
the value we take is 1x4 to the m minus
r but we also know from this
LMA that well this is the best possible
because the total number of closes in
fime is 2
m and the maximum number of closes that
we can satisfy here is m+
R so 2 m minus m + r is M minus r so
this is indeed the maximum
value
so if you can Sol all Optimum value over
searings from here I can deduce the max
set can you maybe um repeat the argument
for the confidence bounding LMA why is
the value of f upper bounded by that
quantity yeah so
that
so I'm going to give you almost the full
argument there is so I'll lie a little
bit but if you don't catch me you will
like
it so the optimal Valu are anyway of the
following form why why that oh that's
comes from the previous well I
personally didn't understand this either
ah so the l i they are not independent
uh you have uh for each Clause you have
XI jxk yeah only one of them will be the
maximum yeah uh so the the numbers Li uh
L1 L2 L3 they are not independent there
are some constraints so I I I don't
understand this whatever those
constraints are once you see that P head
of XI and Pi head of XJ are independent
so the maximum value Pi head of XI will
take what will maximize Pi you know Pi
head of f when you set Pi head of XI to
be Li over Li plus Ki why do you say Pi
Pi uh I understand the first
equality one this one yeah this one is
clear to okay now let's see what about
the second one well given this
expression for different XI they are all
independent I mean p head of all the XIs
is independent of each
other and what about this expression
what will be the value that will
maximize the following expression the
value that will maximize the following
expression is really lii over I plus
k okay and you're saying if you maximize
this one you cannot break the assumption
that this is a maximum yeah because if
there was then you would get something
else I don't know but I'm happy so if
um you have the chair so
huh okay so this is the expression you
get and in this case it turns out I mean
it takes the maximum value when both Li
and Ki are uh
same um the expression gets maximized
over the that and from there we had to
labor through a little bit to say that
this is 1x 4 to the m minus r
okay and then rest of the thing
follows okay so where do we go from here
um well there are two things there are
two results we have one that Mex set can
be reduced to opt well so I have some
very speculative thoughts
um the thing that I find interesting is
that somehow usually if you relax a
problem from only taking discrete values
to continuous values it becomes easier
but that's not the case here so maybe
trying to solve this continuous problem
might be a way to solve some discrete
problems there are lots of continuous
methods being developed because the opw
is really product of Max which is sum of
the log of Max so maybe there is a
better way to solve Max set Problem by
focusing on
the op well and from there you can
generate the Mex Set uh
solution there is some work in the field
of neural networks that have been trying
to look at these kind of logic tension
networks and so on so it might be
interesting I mentioned to some of them
trying to look into it
so
and I have some more concrete thoughts
which are about that the problem is
between FP to NP log and FP to NP there
is a gap here can we try to close this
Gap it we try to get you interested that
trying to close a gap either way is
going to be really
cool maybe the problem is lies in FP to
NP
log well then we know that if we manage
to prove it then there is a lot of work
in Max set
solving we can use those Max set solvers
to solve the problems or the semi rings
and which will be nice because other
problems anywhere it is to set so all of
uh these constraint problems can rely on
the progress in set and me set the me
set solvers don't typically do a binary
search there are very sophisticated
techniques that have been developed in
the field of set and Max set solving so
we'll be able to rely on that progress
to solve the problem
here and of course then there are lots
of questions how do you encode to Max
set and also can there be specialized
algorithm that can outperform set by set
process maybe it's hard for fp2
NP that case one there is a very natural
problem that's complete for this class
because this class is bit frustrating
kind of the only problem that we know
are complete our Lex Max said but even
if you try to convince someone that's a
problem interesting it's usually hard to
convince but this is much more natural
problem to look at so if you can show
that this
is if it's Li in FP to NP then how do we
design practical algorithms that can
rely on progress and set solving but as
I mentioned that even for Max set you
don't call these solvers in a blackbox
manner much more interesting techniques
uh that have been developed over the
years so I think trying to close the gap
either way would be interesting we have
tried for a while and we don't know how
to go about it so I would like to invite
all of you to join this adventure so
with that I'll conclude I'll be happy to
take any
[Applause]
questions we do have time for
questions
yes there is a a related problem which
is about you take a
valuation and you you look at the value
but by only the positive literal you
multiply them and then you try to look
at the maximal value and this we know
this is
Max so it's not exactly the definition
you
have but
yeah definitely I think but there are
some related program that we can
translate at least we think that we can
there is no mistake we think that we can
translate to
them yeah I think that would be so you
only look at the
positive um we no in general we can even
uh I don't remember exactly the
construction now so I it's why I went to
the positive one because I'm sure about
it okay uh but uh but typically normally
definition that we had we could put
different values for the positive and
negative one but typically we just I put
a value for the negative materal and
another value for the
positive so I'm I'm I'm trying to uh
recover the assumptions that you made on
this the sem R so the result you showed
us is they work for the sem R yeah right
so one is assumption is that you you
want the plus operator to be really
Max I mean for because for exess control
and others we have other results that I
did not go into they just reduce the
Boolean case so they are NP
complete okay so one of your
construction was it in each Clause you
decide which literal is a maximum yeah
now if I interpret the Clause sum in the
sem ring it means that the sum must be
equal to one of the uh one of the
elements I'm adding up yeah I think WF
can gave a name to
this selective theor so this is
definitely one assumption that you you
have made here implicit but you also
made some assumption about the minus and
I I'm trying to wrap my head around this
uh the the negation you interpret it as
one minus
Pi well yeah um so you could look at it
it can be you know it doesn't have to be
one minus it is it it will be okay when
if it's C minus some value but uh it
goes go down to the formula that you
wrote here in order to maximize that
Quant the product yeah you need to know
something about yes so essentially
exactly so maybe that will be the all we
want is figure out how do we compute the
maximum value of this expression Pi head
of XI times pi head of not XI so if
there's a compute the maximum everything
is so one minus allows you but some so
in the paper we talk about continuous
like you should take the values so that
you can compute the
maximum we need something to make
progress from
here so that slides go a long way but we
still have time for one more
question okay then let's thanks the
speaker
thanks